hi I'm Eric Voss and frozen twos new
trailer is keeping the tone of this
sequel dark and mysterious leaning into
the origin of Elsa's powers and two
references to Norse mythology and
hopefully letting Olaf survive that
waterfall poor guy looks terrified I'm
gonna break down this trailer
shot-for-shot for everything that you
might missed explain all the symbolism
and mythological connections it spoiler
warning the case into my speculation
it's a be too accurate let's get started
[Music]
[Music]
okay the trailer opens similarly to the
previous trailer with Elsa trying to
have Moana off this beach freezing the
water and falling when the wave breaks
it but there's one new addition at going
from the darkness a voice with this
three note song I have some ideas for
what this could be keep in mind as we
watch the next clip
[Music]
okay is Elsa tumbles beneath the waves a
flash of lightning brings in an
underwater horse creature according to
Disney this creature is called anak a
mythological water spirit that takes the
form of a horse and uses the power of
the ocean to guard the secrets of the
forest the Nook is derived from real
Scandinavian folklore with creatures
called the knockin which is the term
that covers a variety of shape-shifting
water spirits like there was a beca
Hostin translating to brook horse and
the fossa grimm derived from the
norwegian phos meaning waterfall yeah a
lot of these creatures were known as
shapeshifters who would appear beside
bodies of water were riders on to them
and then drown them but others weren't
as bad like the FASTA Grimm played the
fiddle and would offer to teach its
magic and songs to people so perhaps
this nock is the source of that three
note song which we hear again when the
nock first appears and when it departs
[Music]
and just an idea that I'll throw out
there these waves remind me a lot of the
ones that took Elsa's parents King Agner
and Queen Doudna maybe we'll learn more
about that mysterious shipwreck and
perhaps this NOC spirit could be the
spirit of else's mother guiding her
moving on Elsa the past is not what it
seems
you must find ok in this section the
trolls in the first film returned with
grandpappy telling Elsa the past is not
what it seems and there's a flashback to
Elsa as a girl and her mother a Doudna
looking up at the aurora borealis so
again it deunan may play a key role the
mystery of the origin of Elsa's magic
which was something else it was born
with perhaps even something she
inherited from her mother the first film
did feature the aurora borealis and key
moments like who was in the sky on the
night Elsa and Anna had their accident
and it was in the scene where Anna and
Kristoff met with the trolls so perhaps
the aurora borealis is connected with
the natural magic of this world that
horse nock figure returns again in this
sparkly outline which shifts into images
of these giants we see them later on
more in them in a bit and then they
shift into these leaves that swirl and
all these frozen to promos autumn leaves
have shown up again again a shifting
seasonal motif that will be the basis of
this movie here Elsa is wearing that
same purple dress that she wore in the
shot of the trolls rolling up so perhaps
this moment they're learning about these
other magical figures from the trolls
and maybe this is a musical sequence
can't really tell if Elsa's gasping and
Wonder or hitting that idina menzel hi-c
note but next clip across the enchanted
Lambs
and into the unknown
but be careful
okay the voice of grandpappy tells them
to go north to find the truth as we see
Sven Kristoff Olaf Elsa and Anna in a
carriage passing Elsa's ice castle on
let it go Lane he mentions enchanted
lands with a fog covered autumnal Grove
in an interesting shot of Anna and Olaf
and a canoe made out of ice Ana's using
one of Olaf's arms to paddle amazing and
perhaps Elsa made this boat for them to
use and the current takes them into the
subterranean cave over a waterfall which
Olaf doesn't initially see but what is
he looking at it's kind of hard to tell
from those cave walls but there could be
some carvings or rooms perhaps similar
to the ones that we see elsewhere in
this trailer and I assume this cavernous
location is where anna appears to be
stranded in the first trailer and next
there's a shot of the autumn grove
becoming consumed with this pink fire
which we saw a bit of in the last
trailer with Elsa struggling to contain
it here it seems to be emanating from
this glowing orb that bounces around and
climbs trees howl like a squirrel
actually in Norse mythology there is a
rodent figure named ratatoskr just
blanket apology for all my Norwegian
mispronunciations now it translates to
drilled tooth in Old Norse and yeah it
sounds a lot like a Pokemon anyway this
figure climbs up and down the world the
tree spreading malicious gossip to start
a fight between the eagle at the top of
the tree and the angry dragon beneath it
this figure could be based on that or
completely unrelated let's move on we
have all these fiat houses powers were
too much for this world
[Music]
okay in this clip Elsa has seen
interacting with the glowing magic with
the voice of grandpappy talking about
how they were worried about our hours
before but now they're worried that
they're not enough but enough for what
it seems like there will be some new
magical threat to their kingdom of
arendelle and Elsa must better
understand the origin of her magic in
order to overcome that threat we also
get another shot of all these floating
ice diamonds around their kingdom and
comparing them to the poster that was
leaked a couple months ago we see that
these are not snowflakes snowflakes
always have six points but shapes
oriented around the number four with
four unique symbols we'll discuss those
more after the next clip now we must
hope
[Music]
okay the group passes through this wall
of fog it's kind of like a gateway into
another magical realm it's marked with
these four Stonehenge e-type boulders
marked with the exact same room symbols
on the ice diamonds now others have
compared these symbols to the Norwegian
runic compass suggesting these four
symbols could correspond to compass
headings like north east south and west
or they could reflect these seasonal
connection of these movies like they
could refer to spring summer autumn and
winter and some have even tried to
decipher them saying the runes sorta
match characters of the Norse runic
alphabet with one of them when he
rotated 90 degrees to the left flip it
reversed it whatever you got to do it's
similar to the room that translates to
giant that is if you blur your eyes a
lot and pretend things that don't look
at all like each other actually do but
Giants do appear to be part of this
movie so maybe the symbols are for the
four races of creatures in this world
like humans trolls giants other magical
spirits and maybe trolls and Giants are
connected if they're both rock based I
don't know let me know what you think
and let's move on to the final clip I
won't let anything happen to her
okay Elsa hides from this mountainous
giant this giant could be based on the
Norse mythology figure of the jaunt are
the Giants who dwell in joltin heimer
ancient Norse people believed that the
rocky terrain and giant boulders of
their country were carved by giants or
were giants themselves who would turn to
stone when exposed to sunlight these
could be the new magical threats to
arendelle or maybe they're just
misunderstood like Elsa was don't judge
comment down below with what secrets you
think frozen to is hiding from us and
follow me on instagram and twitter at
Navis and subscribe to new rock stars
for more breakdowns of all the things
that you love thanks for watching and
let's hope that final shot of Olaf
screaming a death whale over a waterfall
isn't the last we see of them
[Music]
[Music]